this is so nice and sunny has bit cloudy
earlier but they will be sunshine with
you right
first thing is you notice the
announcement which I will read and
should be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the
building viola nearest available exit
there is one Forex in this room if you
need to evacuate the river do so by the
plants doors for the external fire
escape stuck staircase
please hold both handrails in case the
stairs are wet or slippery if anyone is
unable to use the stairs with a please
there are others straight to the room
before they go to the forest cake door
where they can then be given assistance
70-point will be in the public car park
at the side of the Civic suite please
not delay your evacuation by placing any
belongings please do not return to the
building and two commissioners Dubai
Council of staff and glad please remind
you to switch off your mobile phones
water than water so thank you very much
those that work dog will be fine charity
right apologies perhaps and simply
apologies that we're not members
attending and I think there are you know
minutes of the meeting held on the 6th
of too busy or we shall sign there's a
tree record thank you
anything arising from those minutes not
covered elsewhere in the agenda no any
declarations of interest please if any
should arise during that meeting please
declare them there we've got to make
sure they know
item five matters refer to the executive
and reporters from other committees
there are none so if we go straight into
item 6 which is advice services contract
right so who's following the transfer oh
please I'm happy too thank you doctor
thank you
Thank You members hope you have a chance
to retailers report which I come in to
you just at the outside I'd like to
recognize the work with Sumerian a team
of carried out delivering a valuable and
important service about your district
and I'd also like to know Dex and
welcome Andrew Larry in the ongoing
monitoring and support a RCMP we do need
to go to the market as the current
contract expires next year and just like
to pick up some highlights in a port for
you
I can particularly section three point
five the current advice service contract
has demonstrated its value for money
1617 every pound invested blog accounts
59 pounds is returned to the local
economy which Stoke accounts with two
pounds for every pound and the wider
public sector get every ounce of cost
avoided
indeed in 1718 locally incomes have been
increased by an estimated 186 thousand
pounds primarily through identifying
additional world for benefits the
clients themselves have gained nineteen
thousand pounds in the reimbursements
services and loans I think would agree
these are fantastic savings for our
district
in addition three point six I just like
to draw our attention to the analysis
has been undertaken on a method of
reduction is the value of the contract
even a tempest and reduction in the
price paid by the council to the service
which result potentially in 350 to 400
fewer clients a week and a 15% reduction
would mean six hundred and fifty two
warrants for week so there's a great
risk for us if we thought that we should
be reducing the value of this contract
because if it's benefits to our district
finally I just like to do a members
attention to some of the data at the
back of the document
the monitor that's been carried out too
quickly section six point six which so
show you the spread across the district
is very good positives about service but
do recognize that it's slightly low in
fairness the way concern about yourself
partly because residents to use the
Southland service as well as our own
incidentally we do have a reciprocal
arrangement the South inian enable
residents to access other local citizens
of my services public exceed Citizens
Advice is one organization that did not
really know just families that were
couldn't place pioneers like Tori
attention 26.7 that shows a range of
issues at the CEO be responded to
well their benefits and tax credits of
the Feist
I suspect with the viola of Universal
Credit on horizon I don't expect the
numbers with queries in that section to
increase over exporter so in order to
provide sustainability for our service
it's been suggested that the contract
the two years with in addition of one
year of that or the option for that well
the 12-month contract is the security
that that's what I thought we see
anything
so human support to members
I think this is decision we go
council so for us it's a recommendation
any questions please with this is please
like under the benefits and taxpayers
those figures is anticipated to be more
of a greater or have paint
on the report six point seven there's
so you can see what it has increase it
does dip slightly but what you've got
here is the performance data for each of
the last into the last quarters in the
last year and you can see where that
does it has increased slightly so we've
had seven hundred and forty inquiries
regenerates in March
which is up from 490 in the previous
quarter so it has been a definite
increase in those are accessing the
services around that
you can also see if there's been a start
increasing numbers accessing
unemployment as well and
so yeah the figures actually jordones
the figures a lot of information that is
the way the points we want when it's
carried out
it's very effective and accredit to the
table as you sell think we're about to
switch a little people to universal
credit I think that there's often
cookies despite there's no I believe
that's what resources thing yes if we
look at the data so far the numbers acts
actually asking for information on
universal credit it's quite a load so
for the last book it was only what the
last but it's 31
when you those are put it's rolled out
in this district which I believe is the
next couple of months I would expect
that to have a huge spike actually this
service wasn't here that but those calls
would go straight through the local
authority
and as obviously you know as far as
their SLA is concerned a minute are we
happy that they've got the resources
they need
I know it's it's their bad week if you
like but nevertheless we have an
interest in making sugar loaf for that
yeah I think the value the contract is
fair I would certainly be conservative
forward introducing property merging
analysis as the report says that even
attempts introduction would have a
significant impact on his ability to
deliver locally
it's a be fantastic if we could see the
value increase for that just me where we
are is as except to point seven
delivering value okay thank you yes with
you yeah I'm just interested in the
relationships and family I just wondered
you know we don't you say that probably
does have to do with benefit expletives
I'm guessing in this you know I'm sure
it does have a new because it's obvious
exciting it could be counted in various
other areas so I just wondering from
memory actually spoke about this of the
basin I think it's an honor to a meeting
and one of the reasons for that that
suggested was actually if you go to the
Christmas event holidays because
families become under a lot of pressure
on Christmastime times and finally going
out of relationship seeing other family
members of the may not always see to
that adjutant have a bigger impact
thinking what I think the role of the
president's son explains such a big but
it certainly is a factor at time of year
there's a seasonal thing
whether any other questions
please thanks good report happy to
support it man
particularly the two years will help
give them the stability just is often
made in terms of resource implications
70,000 pounds cash but there is a
tangible value to the other resources
that we give them and for us to
appreciate what the full value of about
contribution and support is I would like
in future to see an indicative value
allocation to denominations
accommodation Carpathia
so yes I think there's a value to all
that and it's worthwhile stating that
just to give a clear value as so much
being given totally agree yes that's
information to feed into the McKenzie
anything needs to be yes nothing I can
go to your counsel yeah I've actually
spoken with Angela about that this week
the estimate should be about just over
six thousand pounds it's based upon
mr. Edison haptic yep
3dj and my community drill down into the
fine for for that profile down to parish
level all of these
we can if there is a specific area that
you'd like information about right so
that's six point six is you know that
goes toward look yeah I think that's
about as far as they can take you you
know that my question is go Knicks
looking down I need to see like they
actually put up to full depth of their
own which vary so check that they've got
to do that I think I've just learnt a
question or air bead what the
information for because always have
become the data collection toss the seer
be the unearthing the purpose behind me
or for a specific time period I'm more
interested in like the universal credit
and the benefit side and onions
appointment chapter there's another
issue in terms of ensuring that the data
is not it's not you're not capable of
recognizing the people involved in this
I think that's
consideration which is now after he
conclusion
I think the dates does go down to
college that you tell anyone yes but
perhaps I mean they could that be
provided in Serbian Segal every week
well this chicken at business we can ask
her and what the people the lowest level
of aggregation of data they can provide
a description say questions we can ask
them whether members are interested
whether they read something and keep in
pnc okay any other questions piece by
members except there's a recommendation
thank you
implementation plan for economic growth
the gs-7 taming the council's adopted
framework for promoting the economic
development in the district the
implementation plan appended to this
report sets out a framework and how the
council will carry out the economic
regenerated functions prioritized within
EGS 17 the four rare variety areas to
encourage inward investment to support
business growth and retention to develop
our skills and the employer ability to
support new businesses the plan covers
the projects and actions that could
realistically be undetected to assist
economic growth within the committed
budget for 2018 19 and a continuation of
the partner partnership working with the
why their business community it provides
reassurance that the council is
committed to economic growth and helping
businesses it also establishes a
framework to guide and how the economic
growth budget will be spent within the
current financial year and that the
following plan ensures
efficient budget monitoring and best
value you will notice that earlier this
week a addendum was sent out to all
members with regards to the key
performance indicators based off one
meeting which we held on Monday with
this policy committee it was suggested
or recommended that we put some values
against the key performance indicators
which you'll notice that's what being
addressed within the addendum I won't go
through all the ten points but I'm more
than happy to take any questions
yes please sir it's not a question it's
just a silly little point you can't grow
the strategy 2017 is that a title that
you use when you're
scribing what we're doing
outside the taps iPod is one of the
venues yes it's just our economic growth
strategy is something that's
forward-thinking in a bit innovative and
looking to the future itself and if
you've got a title I economic growth
strategy 2017 you in the past and if
there was a way of coming up with
something a bit - yeah I think my it
might just help tiny little bit not a
major strategic point but talking about
the future and mention any names of ours
they just don't go together
check and check that back to the
officers in question and we can see a
dress that rose by any other name
yeah yeah no I put on light rays June if
I may
yes I mean we've got multiple
organizations that we do with relating
to economics yes you've got to sell it
we've got all the other authorities
you've got South listings 2015 here yes
and I think it's about the plans that we
have fitting it and working in tandem
the wrong word which is more than -
you're not working alongside all the
other plans that they exist for economic
growth not just for Oxford but within
our region yes we mentioned South in
but I just wonder about the other
organizations that are out there the
promoting growth etc and how this fits
in to their overall strategies Jubilee
there have been talks with other areas
etc and I know the economic development
officers being this approved and took
all these things through so well
proposing is not in this particular plan
I think there's nothing wrong with the
plan we've got here you know because it
reflects Rochford but in the future that
sees a bit more evidence to show that
we've actually considered some of those
other plans that are out there and some
of their partners we're working with to
make sure that you know we're actually
putting together for the same thing you
know in that way that we can show that
to achieve a particular thing with inter
Oxford or in any other place we can
demonstrate that we might need a bit of
infrastructure or
investment or whatever that would
actually take us forward and take it you
know it's not all rocks for people
working on food that you know that
public out there it doesn't see the
boundaries that we see as politicians
suppose you know and hopefully it's just
over there yes but it's interesting when
you look at I read in the paper about a
particular places closing at rate
that was really weird and of course the
actual place in Rayleigh where is not in
radiance or disability so you know we
don't see those boundaries that others
that's right we see that as boundaries
that are this done but having said that
I just think we need to make sure we
keep Juke ignitions to those other
things that are out there and I think we
know I think by and large you know we've
constructed quite royally but obviously
we work we sow things we've got our Jack
etc but I think there's other things
that happen to the equation as well with
my work with the economic development
tell you what we read is sometime in
October
present to the members a training
sessions to actually show how we're
going to be implementing the plan for
economic growth and hopefully it would
cover the points which you've just
raised and we can actually answer some
of the questions for the members so what
was we're aiming for October for the big
training session yeah just pick up what
he was saying with regards to the task
force at the city level County on the
a12 7
aesthetically the detection angle
working with at the moment is free the
one two so we will be looking at all the
economic strategies right where the
corridor are taking them on board as
part
presenting to government okay
that's massive solution because it
literally could connect by taking on
concerns but I think that it is
interesting because the surface of 2050
work is say that since 2015 well into
the future
but I just wondered whether it would be
beneficial at this stage to for for
fathers to introduce an action that does
relate directly to safe let 6 2015 the
reason being that to the key word
streams sir 36 2015 looking at relate to
infrastructure and industrial strategy
and oddly the industrial structure and
pending that stretch Evans and I just
one wonder where there is you know we
need because when this was drafted this
services 2050 was a bit of a twinkling
yeah I know it's only last year but you
know we hadn't we hadn't made that made
the progress that we've made and
wondered whether there should be who can
and thus it ties ties that together
because there's an invisibility that
there will be work in pooting from the
economic officers across South Essex
intersect and similarly as a segue
select one South is it I'm going to be
all these groups and they already to
make sure they were moving in the same
we're not working against each other but
I think someone's fundamentally flawed
she's looking into the future in
different directions actly yeah it's a
point and I think the opening statement
one point one just that first bit that
subject to any comments by the executive
well I think of as comments are that we
need to actually be looking at the
second coming to develop
as gradually working towards 2050 going
forward on that
so realistically that is the comment
that the executive are making and I
think because I'm happy to take that
package to the offices with that support
our men go to work beside their peers to
get some of the other areas I just just
pick it up on right there I assumed it
would be a live document I've been
attacked
yes very many what some regularity
so just from there I accept that the the
document does include a reference to
things that would be we've been talking
about and it does talk about
representing local business interests in
relevant meeting but I think this is
more than that because this is not about
representing people business interests
you know in something like this is 2050
this is about what should be you know an
active part of that effect of that
initiative and I think it's just making
sure that we've got the right person
words in so I think as far as the
comments it concerns point this was
typically ones and those comments should
go in as far as the minister to make
sure that people understand we're
certainly giving that future
consideration I think that's that's
where we go as I said it's not comment
on anything that's been done I think I
think that is extremely useful but I
think you know least it's the world it's
changing all the time if you think about
where we were yesterday where we are
today that's certain aspects you know
things do change so you know you think
you people accept their consideration
but it is about making sure that we
putting that asana sit putting one
direction I was putting in another I
think your father will put in theater
you know one direction helping me Indian
sorry it's just just just very quickly
implementation plan for it
from 2017 because the from means that we
are going all those that's the feeling
that it gets rather than static because
I thought 2017 makes it bit static from
keeps it I think John would say so just
on the only technicality and having the
picked up in the minute I think the
purposes of this report of the term
economic growth strategy 2017 was used
because a strategy was produced in 2017
got here is the KPI two targets
clearly it's remembered intense that's
he gets that that maybe gets revisited
but that's why it was named like that
just just a question real clear about
their one of the key performance
indicators from just six tweet sent yes
fill that maybe look at again with my
wife interviews social media or Facebook
and Instagram lovely just Twitter it
just feels a very loose KPI and per
minute it could be a stomach a part was
doing the whole of social media Facebook
Instagram and so subject to adding those
comments members are you happy with the
decision being recommended I think we
look to perhaps rename this in an
appropriate way which being so maybe the
post slightly different gravy for maybe
and take it into the future okay great
thank you
so that's item seven so item a is
contract monitoring and this is an
quickly Lauren three councils became
officer who actually played a big
detailed information report probably
directional support questions that's a
long time
they're coming to dinner on time so in
terms of of the report itself it sets
out the the process and outcomes of
contract monitoring that counters most
significant contracts in terms of value
and risk it sets out the how the needs
monitored by the hm review our contracts
with in line with the council's contract
passenger rules contract monic that
manages throughout the authority are
responsible for ensuring they've got a
proactive approach to contract
monitoring and we seek to enforce active
training and a toolkit we produced in
terms the work it is it's light where
you can seem to renovate a monitor those
contracts should we get much value once
those KPIs will also go further than
that looking at areas such as health and
safety business continuity and of course
opportunities for efficiencies work with
our contractors members may recall I
reported last year on the top a top set
in terms of value last year the top six
contracts so this year and this report
had gone a step further
I've actually include an additional six
contracts identified through applying a
risk matrix so it's not just our top six
in terms of value is it some additional
contracts looking at risk as well as
found you
so the reports is hopefully registrate
forward and then the appendices they set
out summary each of those twelve
contracting total giving a summary of
the work that is done by the individual
officers and monitoring and responsible
for monitoring those contracts the
report is for note and chairman of
course happy to take any questions it's
interesting to note that when you look
at the ledger contract which is the
contracts we've ever procure being 20
years the fact that the ownership of the
contract the other side of the ownership
of the contract has actually changed so
the strength of the contract is very
often within the contract itself so it's
clearly anybody who comes along you know
and Reese applies to us if you like they
will look at that contract and we will
rely on that contract to keep delivering
that continuity and rely hopefully
reliability of service that we were
expecting so I think one of the
strengths I think we've got to consider
when we're looking at contract renewal
is the contract that was of the contract
itself so I think it's very important
that we were you know where we're
appropriate we received the
advice and assistance they're drawing up
some of these contracts now do we have
any any other sort for any outside body
basics whoever that can help us we're
actually drawing up some of these
contracts
I appreciate this probably a standard
contract for some of the Vark because
remember when we did the contract for
RIT that was a joint contract between
several councils how many was a mountain
you know you possibly run time so yeah
they're very very complicated things so
I'm just wondering how we go through
that process
sure Joe it's we have support from the
brain super cube up so we're the sign
ups not happening for a number of years
now so through that we have access to a
fully qualified became consultant who
supports Lauren in the office two days a
week so we have some additional support
through that but of course something the
more detail contracts you mention IT and
others there be further supports import
those further professional technical
support and they'll go beyond that level
but something in terms of its as you
mentioned that leisure contract and
that's it's an interesting because of
timing in terms of that
that's it so so although we are still
just on the board is out it's starting
now and some months ago with with
looking at citing some some supermarket
testing some evaluation into the market
seeing what's possible the market
although it's a very strong contractors
the German says the wallet has moved on
there's a real positives in there
there's certain things are certainly
progress in sounds written so we're
looking to just talk to the market do
some soft marking testing to see how
we've been really really ambitious for
those less absurdities what they can
deliver the safest starting at work now
and hope it brings light back to
executive later in the year and the
other point if I may your points is that
really one of the two of the things that
we in Telugu Twitter we actually take it
back in-house which could be an option
not that particular contract it might be
something you do once again or indeed
you create that Co all that comes to etc
to take on some of those works as well
so I think that's you know that's the
new thing that's coming forward now so
you need the appropriate consideration
for that it's not just about going
outside off it and putting out a tender
I think there's more to it than that
not very ethical zero options Jensen
yeah okay any other notions will be
silent that's Florida question man
as you can finally the these reports
what's your course of action if you're
starting to see a picture through your
KPIs that isn't matching what you've
been told or the picture we've painted
by the responsible officers for the
contract
so we're saying the contracts not quite
performing as they say it is we would
like that we've got we would flag that
with LT or this is Loretta that's
responsible for that area and from
knowing concerns over the contract we
very much let the contract managers
manage their contracts we only tend to
step in when there are concerns for us
on a day to day basis the contract
managers would take advice from their
assistant directors
to deal with any issues they come back
to us if there's any
themselves as far as what I'm getting at
is we've got reports here and there's
lots of green and everyone smiling but
if it was all red then you beat area and
try to get people to do things and all
of a sudden we've got all these
variables then I would definitely
expecting meetings with contractors and
the contract managers to discuss why
they aren't opening up to the
expectation of the level that is stated
in the contract so they would definitely
have to be conversation
it's not yeah it's not performing
you
if I just ask the following question so
if you suspect that things are not
performing
and this is before it comes to us and
things are raped could be an
intervention program to assure it does
come to as I told you brain
as part of our standard contract
monitoring they should be regular
meetings throughout the year so I
wouldn't expect them to suddenly turn
green before they come to you I would
expect there to be work sushi ensure
that they go green whichever time of the
year just in time we come to the report
for you yeah we we expect officers to
carry out regular meetings that discuss
the performance of the contracts
throughout throughout the year whether
it be called today annually just
following on with with Simon's donkey
question first again cheaters win when
you have these contracts and the idea of
economy you know
having an outside provider the problem
for us is it particularly the long-term
contract is the few looking for
efficiencies unless you've actually
built those into the contract itself
which we have done
it's very difficult to sort of push
efficiencies out we've got a solid
contract and they did agree what they
should do and then you've got to try and
drive the efficiencies out of that
I think it's fair to say that most
contracts that we have by the time you
get to the end of the contract it's not
the same contract that you had at the
beginning we've got travel because
obviously negotiations going forward so
you need to have that way of you know
flexibility if you like both on our part
there's Bryn since I think we booked the
freight liners didn't we for the seats
of serious contract which had she's like
we were saved us English and gosh but
you know cause you know the beginning of
the contract we would never consider it
was all part of it so having said that I
think they know that you have to try
getting again it goes back to perhaps to
the 2050 suffix trying to think the head
you know it'd be lovely if we have this
crystal ball that we could consult and
over the future hair orders for any
but we don't the other thing you don't
want to course is to go with somebody
who's obstinately going to fight because
I think in the past where we've had
somebody could provide a contract for us
particularly good value we've gone for
it but unfortunately the stability that
can accompany it so it wasn't very good
and of course we you know we lost out
and in the overall terms so I think you
know you've got to look at those things
built into the contract now
thank you music was it because I see
three years of counsel ease just to make
sure you know you're following through
but I think that's all going to be part
of what's going through I'll probably
teaching my grandmother circus like it's
worth saying it as much as members need
that reassurance those things are being
done yeah I think just a Thomas I think
it's bad that the proactive approach we
take so it's not waiting it's actually
being proactive in terms of contract
monitoring meetings not waiting
something to happen having a regular
contact and also in terms of the the way
we actually evaluate contractors around
the principles we set that there's a
some pre-cut some key right oh not just
prices yet the quality questions we have
as welcomed evaluators that we're
actually picking up those types of
questions as well about how they would
live with the service what the other
gains as well the other service livery
price obviously rated lots of highly but
they other quality questions behind that
we ask is when I say yeah it's
interesting out and then how that can be
asked
did you a commission no okay
the only other point I wanted to raise
if I may is that I know that in the past
when I've sat on the committee's and it
goes back a bit now we've had many of
the contractors into a review committee
to ask them questions just to have a
look at how things before we go much to
sort of the information that we've got
here really is that a regular feature
now on most of these high-level
contracts in terms of reporting to
review to reassert the letter contracts
been to review couple times last two or
three years I'm not sure about any of
the others by the convention okay it
might be something that might want to be
looked at because clearly if the big
members have concerns perhaps that might
be the avenue that we check that they of
course
so just have a look something it's a
contract review video but we had
overview and scrutiny I think it was
something that you looked at bearing in
mind that they've actually got that
area that they might be consuming they
might have no concerns at all so I think
it's really down to the to the chairman
and the committee s see what they do
with that but it's something that could
be a consideration GP of their members
see some issues
okay you see it's just a fine thing when
we are looking to negotiate new
contracts we have to be absolutely clear
that we want out of our culture and I
think that's a really but we really
didn't have to understand you know what
we want out of it before we go into it
because if we don't
I agree I think some of the training at
Lauren's delivered is all is about and
it's actually about making sure the
resource and the effort goes in early
and there's a Rob to show Nancy shows
the resource at the front end should be
where it's a front loaded we get a
specification right we look at what
service not delivered so when we get
through that actually makes the monetary
be the easier match you deliver the
right service otherwise just say you set
up to fail trade appliance it's
certainly a for us the resources early
on front-loaded getting our spectrum I
think it's interesting when you look at
the recommendation there's a very last
line rules follows recommendations from
external objects so it's not just
they're selling to the look at that the
arocs don't look this is looking at
these as far as the efficiencies and
concerned so I think that's the
consideration we need to give and
obviously listen to any suggestions that
they might make or I think that's
something we really need
so you will be committee I think has a
role here so that goes through
any other points please members
right so it's just to be noted great
thank you
is item nine is here the program
management
yes thank you the members the report I
think it's hopefully self-explanatory
the dashboard has produced a respect of
the two gold projects that are currently
seamless with this this group namely
the housing reduction act work that is
undertaken by the assistant director for
community of the penalty and the ICT
implementation project on the second
fight assistant director for
transformation somewhat irritating me
and I apologize this I notice that there
are two mistakes all of the homelessness
reduction act dashboard they for some
reason the second milestone is shown as
it's red which she completely shouldn't
be give the date hasn't actually expired
and that's excused the assessment of
risk at that at the bottom left hand
corner that doctor says I don't know
bhutesu yes that's on page nine point
six it's the two errors there for which
I apologize
that's that's knocked out that rig
it isn't March 2019 yet anyway
well it's opened up my
this is recited he going through the
report I think it's good that these
things have been monitored judgments
taken about where we are and so on but
give me for saying this but why do we
have to have the quango of calling into
council project program management
office Wow
why isn't it just party job so the the
idea of the of the PMO's is busy and
more easy to pronounce short term is to
ensure that those projects which are
have a financial impact on the MTFs or
have a look at particular scrutiny so
that they are reported separately to
members and that they come to leadership
team as a first line of assurance in
terms of making sure that we're
delivering those those gold projects in
accordance with aspirations set out in
the in T events
I hear I hear what you say
surprising eaters of important projects
that need to be reported but I'm still
not getting the project the fact that
it's identified as a standalone and in
hearing some of the language that is
described and I've seen they say in
other reports as well I think sometimes
the language that we use in he's getting
a bit flowery and sounding a bit
bureaucratic as from a finance point of
view
what I'm saying we need is an absolute
collaborative absolute direction
absolute drive to deliver financial
stability and I just worry when I say
descriptions words however were they
they might be being used that don't have
anything really tangible attached to I
know that the contents of what you
described here that's time to what
that's important forbids its the
packaging that they don't know okay I'm
not sure I understand that one perhaps
become very shake it off line with you
for just us how you present the data the
having spoken with the wolf on
opposition she's keen that we do keep
focus on these key projects so the way
we are keeping them front and center but
if that message is being diluted all
obscured then by all means I'm very
happy to have a vengeance for the trees
sort of thing
so it's about some kids I mean I look at
dashboards in the past and I can
understand both sides of this you know
you've got one page and you've got
various things on it and the idea is
that we the dashboard anything in the
regs it was overview and I'd be like an
an aircraft cockpit you need to know
which instrument is gonna crash the plug
yeah you know and there's lots of
instruments so it's about exposing the
stuff that you need to know perhaps it
could be simplified a little bit we look
at that well there is there is a level
of detail that is one level up from this
you know but I thought prefer to have
more teach there rather than less I
think you know as I said I thought
somewhere in the middle is okay because
I mean I think members need to know the
information but it's picking out the
bits they need to know and that's the
trouble
yeah and that's what we look to officers
to do for us because we're we're like
people in so so chair that is the
purpose of the company report that is
pull out any particular anomalies that
you need done so for example the ICT
project the critical path was read
baseline and that pulls that out very
clearly so that you can understand you
mentioned the homelessness yes yeah so
the as to say from somewhere in Moodle
so perhaps that you say you can have a
grid offline and take you through which
I think refinement is it's just perhaps
into some making bit more user-friendly
you know I think we've done with other
things in the past and you know try not
to over complicated stuff
just to make sure these does what it's
hosted open if you like but other than
that I think it's very very clear and as
you say when you were actually looking
through the verbal side of it you know
the actual sort of you know person
outcomes et cetera makes you some I
think it's very clear what everybody's
saying on the various headings are there
any other points anybody when stories
please members neighbors except the
report you know it's just the latest
version of the project program so there
were truly all the purpose
I think that's the last item just yeah
thank you very much you do